Marvel has evidently wanted to work with
Emily Blunt for some time now the
british-born thespian has apparently
been offered not one but two critical
roles in the MCU Peggy Carter and
Captain America the First Avenger and
Black Widow in Iron Man 2. of course the
former Parts went to Haley Atwell while
Scarlett Johansson has been a key player
in the Avengers movies and Beyond ever
since her MCU debut there are many
reasons blunt didn't take the Widow role
and she herself has claimed it was all
down to scheduling conflicts she refuses
to discuss Parts she didn't accept in
detail however saying it's unfair to the
actors who ended up playing them still
there are plenty of female roles still
to come in the ever-expanding Marvel
universe so fingers crossed blunt will
turn up sometime in the not so distant
future